happy lundi Gras have the little little
ring they gave me last night it's the
Monday before Ash Wednesday I just got
back from my first Mardi Gras in New
Orleans it was unbelievable okay I
attended the crew of Bacchus their
parade 50th anniversary rendezvous
watching more than 30 floats and
marching bands come into the Convention
Center in New Orleans
yesterday was unbelievable late last
night it's one of those surreal
experiences you really have to see to
believe but Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo found another crew dedicated to
honoring our veterans and transforming
their lives watch in New Orleans along
the mississippi APRI parade party is
underway these are members of a Mardi
Gras crew known as the Legion of Mars
Mardi Gras cruise hosts Bowles parades
and undertake philanthropic works
throughout the year but this particular
crew was founded by a group of jag
lawyers from New Orleans Rico Alvin dia
was one of them a few of us had returned
from active duty serving overseas and we
noticed that there was there was no
cruise around that would actually honor
just a military and with so many people
serving overseas we wanted a crew in
Mardi Gras we wouldn't have fun but we
wanted to do something that would
honored the military of fallen soldiers
wounded warriors so many out there of
the 70 plus cruise of Mardi Gras the
organizations that actually parade and
roll through these streets this is the
only one the Legion of Mars dedicated to
celebrating and populated by veterans
as you see rain or shine they're rollin
a little rain could not stop this crew
many of the riders have seen combat in
Iraq Afghanistan and Vietnam some of
these vets
this is not just a parade but an
experience of joy and healing fred
Burmaster and bill trow served in
vietnam together but it was the Legion
of Mars that reunited them after more
than 45 years and changed them for the
better I guess everybody knows the story
about Vietnam veteran how we were
treated and all of this other stuff and
so you know in PTSD so I worry wasn't a
joint and so my wife thought that it
would be a good idea for me personally
to join a group that was you know
catering to vets and it has it's been a
blessing has kind of brought me out of
my shell and you know gave me an
opportunity to meet folks and you know I
feel a lot comfortable being around
veterans caters to veterans and an
active military so we not only get you
to interact with people who had served
years ago like us but we also get to
interact with it with the new people and
people that are serving our country
today
the Hardy here every branch of the
military is honored and before the
parade special mention is made of the
Purple Heart recipients whom the crew
invites to ride with them each year this
float they really went out of their way
to do this for us and we really
appreciate it because so many people
forgot to Vietnam veteran I'm born and
raised in New Orleans I've been to many
careers but never ridden this is the
first time I've ever ridden in 3
[Applause]
it's amazing how much support we get
from the general public people really
appreciate the military and that's why
it's so important for our members to see
that a lot of the guys that might not
experience that when they came back
there seemed out on the streets of New
Orleans he's just fantastic of all the
crews of Marty were all the Legion of
Mars has a reciprocity that makes it
unique
while they toss beads and their hallmark
canteens to the crowd disprove get
something back from parade goers the
respect and gratitude they so richly
deserve Raymond Arroyo Fox News
reporting from New Orleans oh it's
fantastic and the founders tell us that
they named the crew Kate our awwe by the
way after Mars the Roman god of war
because he only fought to secure the
peace